hey youtubers is Charlie music is coming
and Dragons so this is big concert event
that's coming this is just gonna be a
breakdown of what's going on where you
can find stuff you may remember hearing
about this during the summer tickets
weren't on sale yet they're on sale now
there's like a link for the Live Nation
website I'll put it down in the
description
giant thanks to them for sponsoring this
footage this is actually pretty sweet
it's Ramin Java tea headlining basically
from February all the way through April
so pretty you know pretty much like the
first block of next year so if you're
bummed out that season 7 isn't gonna
start till next summer you have all this
game of Thrones experience it's the
orchestra with a choir with this 360
degrees stage
there'll be 3d designs that rise up from
the stage floor so it gets really crazy
it's actually really cool and you
definitely have to hand it to Ramin Java
T I mean he works with Dan and Dave when
he's writing all this music they give
him an idea for the tone but it's mostly
him like he's the guy that came up with
the Game of Thrones theme song that you
hear before every episode but you can
see how the experience is like so much
more than like just a regular Symphony
Orchestra performance it's more of like
a 3d immersive experience like imagine
like if you've ever been into Hall H at
comic-con where they put the screens all
around the room it's kind of like that
Brigadier's like up in it but I do think
they have VIP seats if you want to pay a
little extra
they have like cool house table like
there's like a Lannister section there's
a stark section like right near the
stage but depending on where you live
like just check the website and it'll
let you know which tickets are still
available it starts pretty soon like
it's right around the corner
this is like a complete list of all the
dates so you can actually like pause the
video here if you need to just like scan
this really quickly to see when they're
near your city here's more footage of
what it actually looks like at the
concert like the way it actually works
the way they tailor music for the
experience is actually very similar to
the way they tailor music for the series
I mean the difference being that they
don't March the orchestra behind the
unsullied when they're filming those
scenes so a little bit different in that
way so when he's playing Daenerys music
she'll be flying around on drogon when
he's playing Jon Snow music like Battle
of bastards stuff you'll see the horses
charging out at you and they haven't
released an official setlist but it's
supposed to cover music from all the
seasons like each new season they
actually release an album for like the
new music that's written so there's like
new music for season six Jon Snow gets
some of his own very special music so
you have to imagine they'll be playing
the most iconic songs the red wedding is
the one that always comes to mind first
just because it's so encapsulated the
moment that it was used in in the story
that it told but let me know in the
comments what's your favorite game of
Thrones song I mean the main title is
amazing I mean we listen to it all the
time you literally listen to it before
every single episode but this past
season there was some music from episode
not like naturally episode 9 when all
those Emmys but I think you know one of
my favorite tracks from season six is
called rain obviously that's the
Daenerys track from episode 9 then the
tower as in the Tower of joy from
episode 10 that was probably my other
favorite track which is actually much
shorter but still just very amazing the
way it worked with the way they cut that
episode those are kind of like mood
music to like they're intended to drive
the mood the tone of the scene the rains
of castamere is more of an example of a
really meta diegetic song so there are a
couple different types of songs they use
but if you're a huge fan of Game of
Thrones music as we all are and you've
already rewatched the series a billion
times then be sure to check the tour out
like I said I put the ticket link down
in the description they have links for
like all the different dates depending
on where you live so it's gonna be
pretty awesome well you guys check all
that stuff out you can click here to
rewatch the concert trailer again and
you can click here for all my other Game
of Thrones videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you